10 10. need back up now
he may be outside of his jurisdiction
but that ain't gonna stop old robo from
being tough on crime you are under
arrest dirtbag i mean this dude is
legend
part man part machine
all kind you have the right to remain
silent and you have the right to bugger
off
this is one police officer who doesn't
need a partner
there hasn't been a crook yet who could
outrun the arm
honestly the thugs around here ought to
throw up their hands and surrender to
robocop right now because dead are alive
you are coming with me
no
i must go
somewhere there is a crime happening
[Applause]
you are wanted dead or alive
[Music]
haven't we done this before i have no
record of a previous encounter
we have met
i am sure
fight
get over here
cool
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
you are coming with me
[Music]
tintin need backup now
you are a machine
i identify as human
then you choose termination
fight
oh
[Music]
true
get over here
oh
fatality the terminator wins
[Music]
now
so
[Music]
crime does not pay
you